[Music]
ha no you took chess Louis and my
friends this is grunge in here welcome
to the thirty fourth episode of dirty
chance tricks in this episode I am going
to show you an amazing tricky line
against modern benoni defense and in
fact a mini repre target straight the
opening arises after the falling water
that is d4 Knight to f6 Sifu C Phi now
I'd grab the space on the Queens Knight
with D Phi and accordingly black
challenge divide Center with the moon a
6 after Knight to c3 pawn captures pawn
captures and the moon d6 in the opening
black has voluntarily create a weakness
but in return he gets a tremendous
tactical and sharp activity well the
line I am going to propose in this video
not only contains a lot of tricks but as
per my research there is hardly any
repetition of this line so it will be a
great surprise weapon for you here I
propose the advice should continue with
the move Knight to f3 and even though
black has plenty of choices in this
position I think more than 90% of your
opponent are going to continue with the
move g6 as you can see by the database
this is most popular choice by the black
so let's see what happens when black
continue with the main line that is g6
white will continue with Knight - D -
Bishop to g7 then Knight to c4 so after
a long route this night has reached to a
very good outpost where it can
pressurize d6 square and after the
mooncastle the mainline move over here
is Bishop to f4 which involves a lot of
theory but as usual we are going to
surprise our opponent with this
wonderful move Bishop to g5
now as I have highlighted over here
black has plenty of choices but against
each of them white has some nasty ideas
at six is the main line move and once
again if you check this position in
database you will find out that it has
been played highest combining with other
Queen and the rook moves so let's see
each byte on the first move I want to
consider is the mainline move that is at
six well believe it or not but at six at
this position is not an accurate move
and the simple refutation is white will
continue here with Bishop to F for
attacking d6 so black response is force
black has to play Knight to eight in
order to guard the d6 square and white
initiative will really continue from
here onwards with Queen to d2 so
attacking at six if your opponent plays
G Phi then he's going to severely weak
the light square around his King and I
have attached a sample game in the PGN
where white quickly demolished the black
opponent so the more nature looking more
over here is king two at seven guarding
that six but now comes the very
surprising and a very strong move Knight
to be fine and there are three pieces
attacking on d6 and there is no third
defender for the black and if this is a
male line then line is looking so good
for the white okay let's continue from
here onwards the best reply by the black
as confirmed by the professional chess
engine that is fi so black is aiming to
play G Phi and f4 and grabbing the
bishop but the simplest way to play here
is take the pawn with the bishop and
after Knight takes and Knight takes
white just in the 14th moon come out
with a pawn advantage and those Knights
are wonderfully placed there are not
many games played from here onwards but
as confirmed by the engine this position
is
quite pleasant for the white in almost
all the variations and I have attached a
simple line in the PGN which will give
you a very good idea how to create
winning attack from here onwards so it
is very clear that at six leads to the
pawn drop so how about other moves the
first dubious move I want to consider is
rook to e8 which to my surprise played
more often but after the one simple
reply night to b5 the same problem from
the black can how he is going to defend
the d6 square and you can check it by
yourself it's not easy to play as a
black from this position the best
response goes as follows that is Bishop
to d7 Knight B captures d6 attacking the
rook black plays the counter attacking
move b5
but after Knight captures Queen captures
Bishop captures f6 Bishop captures f6
Knight to d2 finally black grabs a pond
with Bishop captures be tuned but after
rook to be 1 Bishop to c3 and the move
III after the whole sequence white
emerge with extra exchange and I don't
think so there is any sort of
compensation for the black the third
more I want to consider is Asics which
has a simple idea to expand on the Queen
side with B Phi and also stopping night
to be Phi ideas so white response is
force white will continue with a 4 and
here the most popular choice is at 6
because black has stopped the night to
be Phi idea so now this mu looks
exceptionally strong well that's true
but the downside is after Bishop clear
for night to e8 yes indeed night to be
Phi has been stopped but this position
creates another problem in the black cam
that is Queen to d2 King 2 at 7 and now
if i black would love to play here
Knight to d7 to safeguard the b6 square
the problem here is the
d6 pawn hangs and after Knight captures
and Bishop captures white emerge with an
extra pawn and a winning advantage and
instead of Knight to d7 if you open in
place any other moves let's say Queen to
c7 then after Knight to b6 and rook to
e7 that rook will not see a daylight for
a long long time
the fourth move I want to consider is
Queen to e7 which is again the second
most popular choice by the black and
against it my recommendation is why
should continue with the move Queen to
d2 now if you open in place slow moves
such as rook to d8 all the move b6 the
invite has a very simple plan to execute
that is F 3 and E 4 and grab a
tremendous space in the center and maybe
white can look forward for the Kings
Knight attack a sample line can roll
like this rook to d8 f3 Knight B to d7
ephone Knight to e5 move into a fool
Bishop to d7 Knight captures Queen
captures Queen captures and now pawn
captures and after the whole sequence
not only White has an outright passer on
the D file which cannot be stopped but
white also has this bishop pair which is
a great asset in such n games so
accordingly the main line move over here
is Knight B to d7 which has a very
simple idea to put the knight as quickly
as possible on the e5 square but I think
this move has a great drawback as I can
quickly get pressure on the d6 square
with Queen to f4 no surprise that just
like other lines that is not a single
defender coming to rescue the d6 square
the base response here is rook to d8 but
just for your knowledge in case if you
open to continue here with Knight d5
then after the following continuation
that is Knight captures pawn
captures Queen to d2 b6 and the movie
for we have the same kind of scenario
except there is a queen on the bottom so
that's why a Knight to e5 is not a good
idea by black as for the engine the best
response here is rook to d8 so giving up
the pawn in return for the activity but
I think even in this continuation white
obtained a slight advantage a sample
line can run like this Queen captures d6
Queen captures d6 Knight captures d6 and
now black reveal his nasty idea that is
Knight to b6 not only attacking denied
but there's a three time attacks on the
D file so white response is force white
has to capture this piece and after rook
captures white can simply defend the D
fire with E for okay black plays rook to
e8 so now there's a double heat on e4 as
well as on the d5 square and white
cannot defend both the thing so white
has to return the pawn with castle on
the Queen side but after Knight captures
Knight captures rook captures and the
move d6
even though material balance has been
restored
I think this position is quite pleasant
to play as a wide the simple reason is
white has a bishop pair and this pawn is
only two squares away from the queening
I have attached a simple line in the PGN
which will give you a very good idea how
to create a winning attack from this
position considering all the four
options before I think here blacks bass
response is Queen to d7 but I don't
think so many of your opponent will find
this so black has a very simple idea to
play B Phi and get rid of this superb 9
so white needs to stop it with the moon
a4 and now black has two popular choices
in this position the first more I want
to consider is b6 which looks very
natural because blacks planning is to
play
to a six and get rid of this bad bishop
but here comes the super surprise that
is e fo once again released to a
crossroad where if black plays slow
moves such as rook to e8 or Bishop to e6
then white is all set to play f3 and get
our familiar attacking pattern you can
check it out a sample line in the PG n
but the more critical go over here is
what happens if you open and place this
obvious looking move Knight captures
efore destroying the center bone and
what else you can hope for as a black
[Music]
yup indeed it looks very attractive
except there is one problem that white
is completely winning in all the
possibilities
okay first white will grab this piece
and black will try to regain this piece
with rook to e8 and after the move F 3 F
Phi is obvious choice which nab the
piece back before I move on I like you
to pause this video and find a
continuation where white is completely
vinegar did you find it
let's see can you see this wonderful
blow bam hahaha
well it's a clear and sacrifice so right
now what is attacking to sports so black
responses force black has to take this
Nile and now white reveal his nasty idea
that is Bishop to b5 double attacking
Queen and the rook black has to move the
Queen so Queen to f7 and now very strong
mu castle on the Kings side
if black foolishly take this died then
after F captures fo this Queen can no
longer protect the rook and white will
be a simply exchange up so that's why
here the force response is rook captures
evil but after pawn captures with the
naked eye we can easily conclude here
that might emerge with an exchange of
and a far better position the second and
the most obvious response I want to
consider is night to a six when after
that you guessed it White's next move
yup we are going to continue with efore
and as usual if you opponent plays slow
moves such as rook to e8 b6 of night to
be four then we can continue with her
three our great solid and attacking
setup so once again the critical
response is what happens if Knight
captures efore in this variation well
right no order doesn't change because we
are going to capture this nine and after
rook to e8 there's a one game on the
internet where white continued it Knight
to d2 and lose horribly but instead of
that my recommendation is you play this
strong move Queen to e2 well at first
sight it doesn't look pretty because
after fi the situation looks more
horrible but believe it or not it all
tactically justify the winning
combination start with Knight captures
d6 attacking rook and the good point is
now this rook has to leave the e-file if
F captures efore then the simplest is
Knight captures aid and after Queen
captures once again white emerge with an
extra exchange so that's not good for
the black so the first response here is
rook to f8 afterwards in the view of
both of the Knights are hanging white
response is forced but has to take this
bishop black has to take the knight on
CL because if you capture the knight on
the e for the Knight to e7 coming back
in the game with a devastation so hope
to see eight and still it looks like
white cannot save his piece because you
cannot move the knight as rook to e8
will appear on the board but here comes
a star mu Queen to be Phi if black take
the Queen then after a captures be fire
fight is counter attacking the Black
Knight so the only good
ah here for the Blackie's to play Queen
to eat still maintaining the pin but
after castle on the Queen side green
captures d6 so that pawn is only two
squares away from the queening so black
has to do something about this bishop on
the g5 square so the best response here
is at six but after the following
simplest continuation that is d7
attacking the rook pawn captures Bishop
pawn captures rook with a check rook
captures and the sting in the tail paint
check which will not only exchange the
Queen but after the whole long
transaction white emerged with an extra
exchange well I hope you enjoy this
wonderful tricky line against modern
Baroni which not only contain a lot of
tricks but the theory of the black side
is not up to date and you can snatch
some great victories in this line thank
you for watching this video feel free to
like subscribe and comment on my video
and I'll meet you in my next episode
very soon bye and take care